good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is vitoli mere ski I'm the chairman
of the board of the Kosciusko foundation
and I wish to welcome you only and thank
professor midscale for having arranged
this initial dis first event of the
symposium at the kosciuszko foundation
adjust to tell you a few words about the
foundation of which you can well imagine
we are very proud at least of the
building it was established in 1925 by
an immigrant from poland professor Ezra
who was the son of a large peasant or at
least farmers family outside outside
wine suit crixivan and at the age of
eighteen and nineteen twelve I believe
he emigrated to the United States to the
chagrin of his father who wanted him to
take over the farm they had some
connections in Massachusetts and he
ended up in Massachusetts I learned
English there was a Polish high school
where he also learned some English and
he managed to get into Harvard which was
quite a quite an accomplishment in those
years after graduating from Harvard i do
believe he finally got in his Marilla
did he get an MBA or a doctorate at
Harvard won a doctorate at Harvard and
he taught he taught economics that after
at Drake University however in the
meantime Poland became a country again
he decided to do something for others
like him who want to come to the United
States from Poland to study and first he
established a scholarship committee with
the help of the Polish Embassy in in
Washington and thereafter he decided to
establish a foundation and he managed to
to bring into that enterprise six very
prominent Americans he obviously must
have been a tremendous personality in
salesman and for the first until
basically world war two all the board
members where where American prominent
Americans including one who is very
prominent in Poland mr. fontenoy who was
the who led the Kosciuszko squadron for
Poland against the war with the
Bolsheviks which which was also quite
quite an achievement to do to get them
into this enterprise it was decided to
name the new foundation after kosciusko
as a living monument to him and maybe on
the way out if you haven't done so the
Daughters of the American Revolution
very August a group of wealthy ladies
recently managed to attack yet a or had
a clock made and there was a magnificent
ceremony when it was attached to the
wall and and inaugurated sort of a side
story I won't bother you with but there
was a big argument when the kosciuszko
was a brigadier Brigadier General for a
brevet big idea which which was a
temporary Brigadier but they decided
finally to give him the Brigadier
General rank what does a question of
foundation do we have two missions since
day one scholarly and scholarship
exchanges with Poland between the u.s.
and Poland and the promotion of Poland
and knowledge about its culture and
projection of its culture in the united
states that mission has has not changed
we have a endowment of about 25 million
dollars and the we give annually we just
had a meeting of the board last week and
we allocated about nine hundred thousand
dollars to the scholarship program the
most important aspect of that program
for for most of you here is a fact that
we bring in some 30 30 to 35 depends on
on the year and the availability of
funds polish scholars we finance help
finance seven polish programs
American universities are the most
important one being the one at Columbia
University we also we also bring the
only from Poland only doctor'll or post
doc dr. individuals we do have two
commissions one here one in Poland but
they meet finally in Poland to to make
selections we had about six sixty plus
60 Plus candidates and the two
commissions the Polish one in the
American went to an excellent diligent
job we also have a program for Americans
to go to to to Poland to study in year
abroad or other periods of time plus
about a hundred young people over the
age of 18 mainly college students go
under our auspices to Poland during the
summer and some of them receive
supplementary help financial help others
Peter are paying on their own and
additionally we have a large program for
about the same number for Americans of
Polish descent in the United also
Americans not of Polish descent who wish
to study or interested in in Polish
culture additionally turning to our
other mission we have a major cultural
aspect every I can't
how often it is but every two weeks i
believe the wqxr the classical music
radio very highly regarded as concerts
from this from this Hall we also
subsidized various festivals like next
week will be a festival of polish films
and we did also the Chicago Film
Festival we do that for various
organizations and we also have two major
two major musical competition shopping
petition for young people and the voice
competition so that takes us that takes
up all our time and we only have a staff
of 12 or 13 people which does a
tremendous job one of the fundraisers
which we also had last week was was the
annual ball the 72nd annual ball at the
world of Astoria which is on not only
major fundraiser but it also gives us
visibility among polish Americans so I'm
sorry if I took some time but I I'm very
proud of this place I've been on the
board for can't remember nineties it's
it's over 30 years I think this over 30
years and I'm happy that I've seen it
grow and it's a really stable and very
very useful organization I hope it will
continue that way and I do wish you a
pleasant evening and
yes it is miss the professor Mitch
skills turn to say a few words thank you
very much one one one thing I didn't
really mentioned we've been endeavouring
together with Professor midscale to
establish a chair of Polish studies we
are having a tough time raising the
money which is required but in the
meantime we have together with the
Polish Senate established a what is the
official name the kosciuszko central
Polonia foundation distinct this
visiting professorship in over several
studies that was sort of a temporary
bridge until such time as we managed to
to or at least the university manages to
to fund a endowed chair thank you very
much Thank You Vito welcome ladies and
gentlemen to the palace of the critical
foundation it is always a pleasure to be
here particularly when we're doing an
event that is sponsored by columbia
university with our friends here at the
foundation the topic as you know is
german polish reconciliation and there's
a lot to talk about we have we think a
very high power team of scholars from
both countries here to tackle for topics
and in general get into the meat of what
happened to the polish german
relationship in the last few years it
was not so long ago that Professor get
emic was touring the world and saying
that Poland never had such a good
situation as it had in the mid-1990s
when he was foreign minister and Poland
found itself surrounded with seven new
neighbors with whom it had X
relations with the advent of the
well-known changes in Central Europe in
1989 the relationship between Poland and
Germany changed from that of Cold War
adversaries to one of strategic
partnership German politicians referred
to Poland is our France in the east and
hoped for the sort of political
reconciliation that had ensued between
Germany and France following World War
two polish politicians saw in Germany
their best advocate for accession into
the European Union and indeed
particularly after Poland entered NATO
relations between the two countries were
remarkable a new appreciation for the
culture and history of the other arose
and new institutions of mutual
cooperation were established and with
the signing of the border treaty of 1990
in the treaty on good neighborliness and
friendly cooperation in June of 1991 the
path to reconciliation seemed assured
polish president rush nevsky at one
point said that after a meeting with
German politicians that polish German
relations were so good that they had
almost become boring however good
relations between the elites were very
good the reality was a little bit
different prejudices not to mention
certain legal and political problems
remain for example and is a symmetry in
the treatment of national minorities and
the situation deteriorated with the
advent of a dispute over the expulsion
of the Germans from new polish territory
after World War two differences in
foreign policy toward the United States
the war on terror toward relations with
Belarus and Russia increased with the
advent of new political leadership in
both countries in Poland and in Germany
this conference aims to address these
and other issues in two days of
presentations and discussions academics
diplomats and journalists will examine
how each country deals with its
communist past views Russia and makes
pasta politique deals with the myriad
problems lying at the Nexus of memory
history and politics
and sees its own place in Europe and
that of its neighbors is Europe
integrates the sessions of course take
place today and tomorrow and we're
hoping that we have an audience but
since we know better than anybody how
difficult it is on a sunny Mayday to
attract people we're taping this so you
will have a chance to see this on the
Internet after a few weeks now I would
like to invite our two speakers to do
what they're supposed to do this evening
and I think I'll begin by introducing
them both and then asking mr. Mikkel to
make the first statement our speakers
this evening are Marcus meckel who is a
well-known German politician from the
SPG mr. mechel has a very interesting
biography because he's a Lutheran pastor
he's gone through a seminary he was
active before the changes excuse me in
1989 and in fact was the last foreign
minister of East Germany became a member
of the Bundestag I believe in 1990 and
has stayed in the bundestag in a variety
of positions working most recently with
the foreign policy Commission and our
committee I'm sorry and a couple of
other August bodies within the bundestag
he's quite well known in Poland and
that's why we thought he would be a good
person to invite to speak here our
second speaker this evening is my friend
Pablo Zaleski whom I've known for quite
a while mr. Zaleski is a sociologist he
is a member of the law and justice party
like mr. myko he entered politics after
the changes rather quickly and was a
member of the same already in 1991 the
first term of the new
polish parliament after the changes in
1989 today he is not only a member of
the Parliament but also the head of the
parliamentary Foreign Affairs Committee
somebody who i believe does everything
that he can to throw cold water on
emotions as they arise because of
different things that are happening
today between russia and estonia for
example so without taking up any more of
your time let me ask please mr. Mechel
to make his remarks dear mr. Minsky chip
Javed is a general consul dear friends I
am happy that you invited me to have
some remarks about the german-polish
relations today and that's connected
with your big question all the time
during the last more than 15 years it's
exactly 50 years ago that i had another
conference here in New York about the
german-polish relations that was run by
the thing about foundation some of you
will know mr. Gaeta dead care and I was
together here this human ambassador the
Polish Ambassador in United States and
he in that time was the first time in
united states the a news writer and we
had together here discussion about that
relationship in the european framework f
it was a very short time after all that
breaks and new beginning in europe and
if i look back to that time with the
discussions of that so i can tell you
that all what was discussed in that time
it was the european integration
and the question of security for Poland
all that is fulfilled in a very short
time I would say so and so I think if we
see the situation between Germany and
Poland i would say that in German
distribute is better i'll still
re-established shrestha i still are the
feeling is worth that effects are and
I'm very sure that exactly that's the
case if I see the relationship and the
contacts between German and polish
society if I see the culture and
economic contacts and cooperation if I
see the investments from Germany in
Poland but vice versa more MORE it's
vice versa it's a growing polish
investment in Germany in Western Europe
if I see the partnership between towns
and cities it's a marvelous success
which has happened do list last one and
a half decades and if you will see the
polls what the population is thinking
about each other then it's a marvelous
access to great majority in Poland is
thinking about Germany in a good way
much better than some years ago and it's
a similar way for Europe the feeling and
the positions towards Europe a much
better than three four five years ago
including for instance the European
Constitution if you see the population
that's clear that there's a a symmetry
between
only and Poland in dealing to each other
and have the awareness to each other but
i would say that asymmetry has a basis
of equality because both junk and polish
people are looking west what the
difference is if the Polish population
is looking less it's looking towards
Germany if the German population is
doing the same they show the back to the
Polish people from that we have set as
batteries and some difficulties in our
population the readiness foreign
students to learn the language the
ladder is to visit the other country and
all these things if you see that
integration process which was the most
important aim of our governments in the
90s it was clear that this way was very
much connected with Germany and you
mentioned it you mentioned it in the
beginning that Germany was very much
engaged in that support for Poland in
that integration process so I think that
we can look back it's really a success
story which happened between Germany and
Poland during the last one half decade
if you look too that's a new situation
that Poland is member of NATO not only
but also member of you then this
equation what is the self understanding
in Poland of their own role in Europe as
a chairman of the german-polish
parliamentary group we tried i think it
was in 2000-2001 during the negotiation
process we tried and we succeeded to
make common paper the polish german poly
methyl group in the german-polish one
about the future of Europe and about
their own role they're all these issues
which are dealt in the European
Constitution we discussed in that time
and it was not so easy to concentrate to
that question because usually the Polish
colleagues wanted to talk about the
negotiation process and not the
conditions of negotiations possessing
all these difficulties in that way but
it was very difficult in the beginning
to abstract from that to say let's talk
about if you are in what do you want if
you are in which road you would like to
play I think that's not so easy question
if you are in such a community which has
their own roles at the most of them are
unwritten would because for many issues
you need consensus and the question of
the relationship of national interest
and the interest of the camel process of
your own it's not so easy to describe it
is and it's not so easy to solve that in
the concrete situation and so I think it
was and it is not astonishing that after
2004 there where some difficulties
especially to that role and not only in
2004 but beginning during the years
before you remember the difficulty is to
find the current position the question
of the Iraq war and all as a synonym for
the letter of the age that was a split
of Europe some days after European
countries found a command position and
after that it was split in a short time
the other question during in the
beginning of the of the dis decade the
discussion about the European security
and defence policy if I see the last
years after 1999 when we made the
decision of the cologne summit to begin
with that process we had a very
skeptical US administration in the
beginning with Clinton then they
understood after a time but with Bush
began again to be against and to fight
against that we know that it has changed
until now but the polish position was
very much connected with the American
position in that time in the question
what is the role of Nate
and what is the role of European Union
in security matters if you see the
question of European Union thoughts
easily world perfect of casual tomorrow
about that and so I think it's a mixture
of experience in some of that issue we
have a Polish position which tries to
find a new way in all way and sometimes
against against other for instance
Germany other countries or in others to
find to look for community and to look
for Alliance for that that's especially
the case if you see the policy towards
east I think that it was a very
important event when we had a ranch
revolution in you claim that the Polish
podran evolved there as a represent as a
representative of European Union it was
his own understanding and it was
accepted of other European countries
especially Germany and so I think that
is a growing understanding that we have
to have a camel repeal position towards
east which is not so easy as we know if
you see the situation and gala of Poland
is very much engaged in that process but
in that double process on the one hand
not to exclude barrels but on the other
hand to support a change and especially
to support civil society and the
opposition and I think that's important
and we try to do it together but we
together see that you've been Union
has good proclamations in that field but
very little really support and so we had
the idea and we are working for that for
instance tough to establish the European
democracy foundation which in my view
really would a good answer for that
until now we didn't succeed with that
and we have the question of Constitution
we know that difficulties and the
difficulties comes from the journal
support and itself we sometimes have
some doubted well if it was right to
support suit to support Poland in that
situation because in that situation it
seemed to us very important to have the
similar better voting situation for
Poland but if you see the general
situation in Europe it's a difficulty
and so we germs sink and not only be
that with a double voting it's a more
justice situation on the one hand to
have the population on the other hand to
have states and so little states have
the right to take part but it is on the
other hand clear that that states with
large at the big population can't be
over voted because it's not possible to
have a vote with all the little states
and the larger one in the more financial
stronger one have to pay and so I think
that total double voting for Europe is
really the best way and we have to
discuss it
today is the constitution day in poland
and i would say in that time third of me
that was the first written you've been
constitutionally with the separation of
the palace in that time power poland was
at the top of the european process in
the constitutional way and i would wish
that Poland is going there again that
would be really a fine development I see
that we have today have lady some
difficulties in that European issue peak
not only because of some really
difficult questions but also because of
not so clear polish position about their
own role in your own and I think that
would be an important issue to discuss
tomorrow during the next time I think
that sometimes if I talk with
politicians from the different parties
sometimes in Germany people ask me why
if the government is not so much in
favor of that European process of
integration why there is no polish
opposition taking the issue and define
themselves as a clear you bean porridge
party but that's not the case if you see
this on the one hand is to see platform
platformer roketa was it in the
beginning you said litza or the debt and
so that process is not only a process
of one part it's a process in Poland at
all I've come to shorten it come to
Russia I think that in Europe at all
there is known not much awareness about
the Polish experience with Russia and
not only with Russia but also with the
situation in between exactly that's a
deep experience in Poland and nobody who
will try to understand Poland has to
forget it and that's why it has to be
remembered and it's not only Poland if
you see the situation of the Baltic
States if you see also pillows in other
states in that former European eastern
border and Russia there's a field of
history which Western Europe is not
really aware and so it could happen that
that event of the 60s anniversary of the
end of the Second World War was shaped
in that way as we experience and I think
there will be a majority in that room
not only to say that must not happen
again we have to deal with that history
in another way then what happened in may
2005 in Moscow under the line of pudding
but is the question for all of us it's
not all this equation for Paul the
question of European Union and I think
you've been unions identity is very much
linked with that and we have to shape
data to prepare that I will come back to
that again I think that from that
background
it is understandable the discussion in
Poland the question with the Baltic Sea
pipeline between Russia and Germany and
the European Union it's one of the
European energy lines and in the end it
is clear it will be built but the
communication of Chancellor Shona in
that way was a catastrophe because it
was not really consulted it discussed
before and so I think that's one of the
difficulties the other thing is involved
not to reject the participation during
orakpo in my view that was right but the
question was in which way that was
celebrated between Germany France and
Russia and that so-called I would call a
little bit worse so called ex situation
so that middle powers of the European
Union together with Russia that brought
some difficult feeling and polling but
the problem was on is in my view that
today when pull this member of European
Union is not that poet was not in the
effect was not demanding a common
European position towards Russia now we
try to do it but it created in Poland
feelings against European Union because
you pin union is led by France and
Germany and that's why we don't like it
but in my view it's a very important
issue for the future that you've been
union with such important issues has to
shape a camel position towards Russia
and I think the roundabout way if you
see the rational restrictions with meat
from Poland in the beginning it was
difficult that behavior of the
Commission but I think for a long time
it's very clear that says European
solidarity with Poland in that field
reading it at the last point of the GOP
issues the question of mutual defense
I'm coming now from Washington talking
about that in the State Department and
which the Congress and Senate and I
think that we had god Joey the last
week's a marvelous common communication
offensive of United States towards
Russia and I think that was very good
that visit of gates to Moscow loss was a
very important visit and that he offered
compilation and in that field
and it was very clear for them and if
you see the complete details it's clear
that what has to be stationed in Poland
in that plan is nothing against Russia
but the feeling Russia then the feeling
in ponent seems me to be that there's it
casually do their small decision until
now and we listen and hear what the
position are or will be but it seems to
be that the background for supporting
them united states is more Russia than
Iran my feeling is that important
there's no clear feeling to be
threatened by Iran there's more feeling
to be threatened by Russia and so it
could be interesting difficulty the
United States is trying to convince your
peak countries including Russia that is
only against that threatening Iran and
in the same time especially important
there's a feeling we have to do it in
order to be more secure from Russia from
possible threats from Russia and on the
other hand I think the background could
be that says a feeling in Poland that
it's needed a special relationship to
the United States to get a more secured
situation and if that's right and that
would be interesting to talk about if
that's right then it would be a problem
because if that would be right then it
would mean that membership in NATO is
not enough and that could create
difficulties in
with regions of a different security and
that could be a problem and so I think
we have some questions to discuss in
depth I will finish with the question of
the so-called how to say it does its
political history policy or what what
what historical was but historical
policy okay in the title of that
conference here is a question polish
German reconciliation looking back it
was mentioned that Josh nasty set is a
boring situation between Germany because
all things are so good we remember that
some journalists in the end of the 90
set it spoke about I don't don't know
how to say it in English for generals
kitsch can you translate I don't know
what reconciliation key shock so easy
okay and but now we are far away from
that we are far away in the 90s at the
end of the 90s I inhaled 10 years ago i
experienced a confidence in warsaw about
the question of expulsion and it was
astonishing not only for me but also for
instance for the check beseder in war
zone he took part in the conference and
abort that discussion that open
discussion about that and he said
afterwards that he couldn't imagine that
this output kind of dealing with that
pass was possible today we are far away
from that but the question is why
one important reason is that plan of the
association of expert people association
in Germany with Eric Ashton bath they
plant in the end of the 90s and from the
end of analogies to establish so-called
sent against expansions in Berlin this
was in the time of the red clean
government when we cut some budget for
that is association and if we see the
situation of that the situation of that
Association people are going old and
order to be order an order and the
questions what will be the future and to
find a new sense for them seemed to me
one of the most important backgrounds
for ill Akash language and the red clean
government was against that plan I
myself I am very much info in favor of
dealing this past that we never have and
must not push away our own past we have
to deal with to win the future I am
convinced about that but that includes
six paths should question too I grew up
in eastern part of germany and there are
many of that people that experience they
never could talk about that and deal
with that and that's why I think that
history has to be dealt with not only
the private but only but also into
public way but the question were was and
is in which way it has to be done and so
we had the strong debate during the last
five years I can't repeat it in detail
way I made the proposal to do it in them
in European conversation and
communication together and to build into
shape come project
are an ethnic Adam Minsky and other
supported it but it was not it doesn't
come and didn't come to the end then we
had the situation of election in Poland
and Germany and so we set the germany in
the grand coalition because the
Christian Democrats were much in favor
of such a center and we are social
democrats against and so we made the
compromise with compromise to establish
embedding a so-called this parasite and
I seeable signal a sign sign for that
and nobody in that time knew what could
it mean now we have discussion there and
the proposal is and of that what was
very important to say let's do it in
Berlin that was a point in which this
glitch Democrats won in that coalition
negotiations we want in that point that
we said we will never do it without
communication with the neighbors and we
don't with with us such a center will
not be possible and so we can only do it
together and so the discussion continued
it is continuing but I think we are a
good discussion now it's clear now that
the basis of that what will happen will
be an exhibition an exhibition from the
house Tiger shifter which
was shown in born in berlin and like
this we will have judge the next week's
or monsters and international workshop
with historians from Poland Czech
Republic and other international
countries over to have to judge about
that concrete exhibition to say what has
to be changed in our view what has to be
enlarged in which way it has to be
Europeanized hatch discussion will take
place and fran from that basis it's
planned to give that changed in the end
change exhibition a place in berlin that
is a plan we have known last point is a
question of the so-called network
solidarity and remembrance inside area
that was initiative to talk in the
cross-border way together with our
neighbors about historian issues the
beginning what it is casual about
expansion but if you see the text it's
the question of dealing with its twenty
century at all but i really think that
it would be very important right it is a
very important project which could help
us in many fields of discussion about
that historical policy i mentioned the
question of the end of the Second World
War I take for instance I think that
would be a wonderful project to deal
with what I could call the European the
European heritage of freedom beyond the
Iron Curtain if we see and we don't know
each other enough who Germany knows
about the uprising of
56 and personal almost nobody who in
Poland is really knowing about uprising
in 53 in Germany many things many are
thinking that were only some people in
Berlin the Carmack sorry but if the end
it was more than 1 million in more than
700 cities and villages edit all these
things we can act many things to that I
think it is a European challenge that we
together right down and research as a
part of European freedom heritage that
you peeed freedom heritage beyond the
Iron Curtain I think that's a very
important project we have to do it
together and with that proposal I will
come to and because I see it's too long
Thank You mr. Mekel mr. Zaleski
your excellences dear mr. chairman of
the kosciuszko foundation in the United
States yannick dear Marcus all of you
distinguished guests I'm like first of
all thank you very much for organizing
this conference which is my opinion
about very exciting topic and very
important for Europe it deserves higher
attention because of the recent
development in German Polish polish
German relations as well as because of
its importance for the future of the EU
I would like to concentrate on some
important points connected also with
reconciliation process between Germany
and Poland Poland and Germany and then I
will try to answer some points Marcus
had just rise during his introductory
speech first of all I would like to
start with a important in such situation
statement that looking at history polish
German German public relations have it
never been so good yesterday poland and
germany are in the same military and
political alliance nato we are in the
same political economic institution
which is the you and that is a very
important framework for our relations
it of course doesn't mean that there are
no problems and that there are no
question points but I think that it is
quite normal especially in Central
Europe the region with such a difficult
and in many respects painful history
after 1989 after the Solidarity movement
in Poland when due to its activity
Poland regain independence and it opened
the process of rigor ization of
liberating of the Central European
countries it was also the starting point
for unification process in Germany the
time for the right reconciliation
between poles and Germans came of course
we do remember this what I can name as a
reconciliation keech between official
eastern Germany government and polish
communist government starting from the
50s but of course Marcus and we know
exactly that it was not the real
reconciliation the time for that came
after nineteen eighty eighty nine and it
was the time when the basic treaty
framework had been created and the time
when the both governments decided to
start the policy of which was focused on
Poland's integration into the
transatlantic and European structures by
the way it was one of the most
successful projects which had been
executed between poles and Germans
but of course to understand what is the
current level of reconciliation we
should go back to nineteen eighty nine
and to the situation in the both
countries first Poland Poland was the
country were the current government as a
matter of fact did not allow did not
create any frameworks for
reconciliations with any neighbors as a
matter of fact the process of
reconciliation their actual
reconciliation started by different
independent institutions or underground
civil societies representatives the most
important was a church catholic church
with this friendly move towards Germans
we are forgiving you and peace forgive
us everybody remember that and it was
important extremely important to start
the process after nineteen eighty eighty
nine but on the polish side we still
expected much for going openness from
Germans much for going companies for
understanding of our history of our
position of our problems of our pain as
well then the German side Germany went
through very successfully the process of
reconciliation is France and it went
through the process of democratization
and in beginning of 90s Germany Germans
for themself quite confident and felt
themselves as the nation which as
sufficiently changed it its history of
course I've been changed it's a attitude
to the democratic change its attitude to
cooperation in the neighbor neighbors it
is what I meant and of course it created
a symmetric situation when Paul's
expected much more from Germans and they
felt that Germany was still the country
which had a kind of a depth towards it's
not only Poland but also Eastern
neighbors Germans in my opinion thought
that as a matter of fact this
reconciliation and integration into
democratic societies has been finished
so the level the temperature I would
means this I would say as a temperature
of mutual expectations the temperatures
were different and today we have some
consequences of this situation Marcus
mentioned that during last times last
year's we are managed to do to establish
a lot of very positive very friendly
relations for example between the cities
that is the truth but compared 600
agreement between polish and German
cities with much more thousands of
respective agreements between German and
French cities the district alia
symmetric German Marcus is right saying
that Germans are looking westward it
means they are looking to France France
is the natural part of the natural
neighbor for a lot of
poland is not known talking to many
Germans mainly coming from the western
Germany who came to Berlin and leaving
Berlin right now poland for them is
totally not known country even if the
border between Poland and Germany is 60
kilometers from Berlin something like
that so they have never been to Poland
they can travel a lot of kilometers to
France but they have never been to
Poland yet so this is very important to
understand the situation between our two
to two nations so this is a kind of a
background then coming to the process of
the problem of understanding of
responsibility in my opinion that is a
key difference between poles and Germans
the key difference which creates a lot
of troubles poles tweet responsibility
for history for for example what
happened in Second World War as a
collective one as a responsibility of
the nation as it as a whole Germans this
is my first illness treats
responsibility as a issue of individuals
and this difference is a key for example
for the problem of expelled Germans
Germany because sergeant Second World
War is the problem of the state my
family had nothing to do with it
therefore we should not pay for it and
this is extremely important to
understand and of course this attitude
is not understand are understood by
polls and polls to not agree with this
kind of argumentation but of course we
have to we have to know it so i think
that products only publish membership to
the you created some new problems in our
relations because it opened the floor
it's open the rule for german expelled
people claims to our country because
before before our membership for for
many Germans it's sent you jealous it
seems useless to to write this disclaims
so they as a matter of fact started to
be announced just around 2004 so it is
it is very clear coincidence then the
problem of the polish minority in german
the something calls are very important
because there's a lot of poles living in
germany some from two or four
generations that is immigration from
gilga polska region to for example
madrid north rhine in the end of 19th
century there are also a lot of poles
living there who came just recently and
when we compare the situation the
position of the both minorities in the
respective countries we can see very
high as a metric
right it is also sounds like important
for the Polish government to rise the
standards for the Polish minority which
by the way is not officially recognized
by the German state the last important
thing the relations with Russia I think
that it is the other key issue because
in last year's and it did not happen it
did not it had not started after last
elections in Poland this is a process
which started to be visible in 2000 2001
2002 on one hand side we saw and that is
the Polish perspective I know that my
German friends question is it's not
important but as Rick validity but our
our personal is that that time in
Germany some politicians and historians
just making the different accents on the
history started to in some way we
interpret the history because if we
concentrate our interest on what
happened to Germans in 1944 1945 and it
was horrible bombing of marine or
threaten or many many other cities
German cities we can understand also the
explanation of German citizens
because a lot of poles were expelled as
well so if we concentrate our historical
researches and public debate on these
issues we create the balance between who
was guilty and who is a victim in our
personal asst there is no balance and
that is still something vital in Poland
and important to to understand and this
process has been associated with the
other process with the process of closer
relations with Russia and of course you
can imagine knowing the Polish history
the dis kine dove cooperation over our
heads always creates these questions
many doubts and that is something called
we do fear the most and of course we
understand that at the moment we are
acting completely different frameworks
that at the moment the German government
is a fully democratic government and the
German society is democracy gets a
society but still this remembrance from
the past are important for our
historical and political understanding
and i would say imagination that is
about polish german relations but Marcus
is absolutely right saying that these
relations are crucial for the future of
the I'm just checking how much time do I
have I think that it's not too much
so briefly in my opinion polish German
corporation has the same importance for
the future of the you as german french
corporation had for the creation for the
foundation of of the you because Poland
being the biggest Eastern European
country new member of the U has a
special responsibility also has a
special ability to represent the
interests of this part of Europe in the
process of unification of Europe as a
whole I mean this polish German
cooperation is crucial for fulfilling
the economic and social unification of
the continent what is a marvelous target
remembering that these divisions is
economic social divisions in Europe
started in Middle Ages so the project we
have now to fulfill as just to overcome
the history extremely long time of
history in very short frame of time and
that is the crucial thing and I think
when Marcus asked for the Polish
understanding of its role of the
Poland's role in the you that this one
of the answer lonely lonely the first
one the other answer is that
understanding the problems of security
in eastern central Eastern Europe this
is also something what Marcus has
mentioned
we can put a lot into the common
European security especially maintaining
and calling for maintenance of Chronicle
or for maintaining of strong
transatlantic relations and I'm very
happy with the current government to
Karen German government policy which has
been changed after the elections the
policy just in favor of transatlantic
relations in favor in favor of relations
with the United States because in my
opinion what we all need in Europe is
just to have the United States strongly
in in Europe strongly interested in in
Europe and so these are the two the two
important roles and the third is to
spread awareness for the Holy you of the
importance of Eastern European countries
which at the moment do not belong to the
you like Ukraine like Valerius like
Madhava like Georgia and that is also
something what Marcus has as mentioned
I'm just trying to answer the question
in the most important questions there is
one very hot issue which is discussed in
Poland and in Germany right now and in
the States as well I guess I mean the
anti-missile should and Marcus mentioned
something important he said that Poland
expects something more in the United in
the relations with United States than
the rest of the NATO countries what is
danger as far as I understood Merkel's
because it could create the different
security standards was I right just
summering your remark well so first it
is very important argument which I try
to answer in Germany first it was at
Poland who started this kind of policy
if Pollard had started it was Germany
with the Nordic Nord Stream pipeline
because this Nord Stream pipeline
creates evidently the double standards
of security in energy this is something
we always discuss but if we are talking
about the polish Polish American
relations and strengthening our position
I would like to say that everything we
expect is in the frames of NATO not
outside NATO this first second I'd like
to say that considering the current
situation the current policy there are
different standards of security within
the NATO countries and I would like to
say that Germany as one of the strongest
security standard having American bases
on its soil and if we also go more
detail I wouldn't like to do it right
now but if we go more detail into the
contingency planning what is important I
would like to say that still there is a
lot to be to be done to strengthen not
polish security but European security
because in my opinion just closer
relations and closer American relations
engagement into Europe it's not only
important for Poland is mostly important
for Estonians
for Latvians for romanian especially if
you are following the relations of this
country's today with russia so i will
believe that finally we will find the
agreement finally we will find the way
to create very important polish german
project for europe thank you thank you
both gentlemen rather than do what
academics usually do which is now to
engage in a long discussion will be
doing this all day tomorrow I suggest
that we use the time that we have to go
downstairs and have a glass of wine and
talk to our speakers individually so I
would invite you to lead the way thank
you very much